schwere Explosionen im Zentrum von Kiew
dicker schwarzer Rauch über der Stadt
mehrere Raketen sollen hier vor wenigen
Minuten eingeschlagen sein berichtet
auch Kiews Bürgermeister Vitali
Klitschko seit Ende Juni gab es ja hier
keine russischen Luftangriffe mehr jetzt
wohl gleich drei laute Explosionen
mindestens 15 Menschen sind verletzt und
es soll eben auch Tote geben zuvor gab
es ja Drohungen aus Russland in Russland
macht die Ukraine für die Explosionen
auf der krimbrücke verantwortlich und
zugeschaltet ist jetzt Professor Doktor
Joachim Krause vom Institut für
Sicherheitspolitik an der Universität
Kiel Herr Professor Krause wie bewerten
Sie die jüngsten Angriffe der Russen
jetzt auf die Ukraine
ja guten Morgen das ist die Sache des
kleinen Mannes im Kreml für die ja die
Anschläge auf die Brücke über die krimen
die ja doch einiges bewirkt haben und es
ist natürlich auch die Rache dafür dass
Russland in die oder erst das ist die
Ukraine geschafft hat Russland in die
Defensive zu drängen was die
Kriegshandlungen mehr trifft und das war
zu erwarten dass so etwas kommt und
es ist natürlich militärisch völlig
sinnlos was hier passiert das geht nur
darum zivile Ziele zu treffen die
Menschen zu verunsichern und innerhalb
der ukrainischen Bevölkerung eine Art
von Frustration herzustellen die sich
aber meines Erachtens nicht einstellt
sondern eher das Gegenteil ist der Fall
die Ukraine hassen immer mehr die Russen
und nicht nur Putin sondern auch die
Russen und das führt dazu dass dieser
Krieg auf der ukrainischen Seite
weitergeführt werden wird diese Rache
des kleinen Mannes sind Kreml wie sie
sie nennen ist das jetzt nur eine Punkt
alle Reaktion von Putin oder sehen wir
jetzt tatsächlich eine neue
Eskalationsstufe im Krieg
nein das haben wir bisher ja immer schon
erlebt dass die Russen wenn sie irgendwo
an die Niederlage haben einstellen
müssen auf die wilde Ziele
zivile Ziele angegriffen haben das hat
mir letzte Woche auch in unserer erlebt
einfach
Ziele anzugreifen mit Raketen die
sowieso nicht sehr zielgenau sind aber
die sehr viele Schrapnelle verschießen
können das ist im Grunde genommen reiner
Terror aus Verzweiflung oder aus Ärger
das ist nichts Neues ist so es ist auch
keine neue Eskalationsstufe nur die
Russen müssen aufpassen dass die Ukraine
nicht mal auf die Idee kommen vielleicht
auch den Kreml anzugreifen wir haben ja
gesehen dass sie in der Lage sind auch
für sehr ungewöhnliche Methoden
einzusetzen und vielleicht Schicht geht
es auch mal in der andere Richtung also
das in amerikanstelle etwas vorsichtig
die Ukraine rückt immer weiter vor Putin
verliert immer mehr Gebiete steht quasi
mit dem Rücken zur Wand heißt es immer
wieder wie gefährlich ist ein solcher
Putin
er ist natürlich gefährlich aber man
darf ihn nicht vergleichen mit Hitler im
Führerbunker die Situation ist eine
andere dann die Ukraine stehen nicht 20
km vor Moskau das ist ja der große
Unterschied er hat jederzeit die
Möglichkeit diesen Krieg den er beendet
hat den er angefangen hat zu beenden und
das kann auch machen ohne dass er gleich
hier sozusagen sein Leben verliert aber
putin ist fest entschlossen diesen Krieg
zu seinen Holsten weiterzuführen und und
vor allen Dingen siegreich
weiterzuführen und er zerstört im Grunde
genommen die Basis das russischen
Militärs und auch die ganze Basis seines
seines Gesellschaftsvertrages mit der
russischen Bevölkerung das scheint er
offensichtlich nicht mehr wahrnehmen zu
wollen und das führt dazu dass
letztendlich die Basis seine Herrschaft
doch dadurch ins Wanken geraten könnte
kurze Frage noch immer wieder das Thema
Atom Drohung in der Luft für wie
wahrscheinlich halten Sie es dass dieser
Krieg in diese Richtung eskalieren
könnte
ich halte das die unwahrscheinlich vor
allen Dingen nachdem die Amerikaner
jetzt eine klare Warnung ausgesprochen
haben aber unwahrscheinlich heißt nicht
dass es völlig unmöglich ist man weiß
nie was dort im Kreml alles ausgebrütet
wird aber ich halte es für nicht sehr
wahrscheinlich aber nicht ausgeschlossen
reiner Terror aus Verzweiflung sagt
Professor Dr Joachim Krause vom Institut
für Sicherheitspolitik danke Ihnen heute
Vormittag gern geschehen
[Musik]